this is the consumer price index it's at
the highest point in 41 years
to bring it down the federal reserve
pushed through the biggest rate hike
since 1994 in june and is expected to
keep raising rates at the fastest pace
in a generation why is the fed going
against the slow and steady pace that
they've said is best for markets and for
everyday americans to put it simply
they've fallen behind on reining in
inflation i'm going to break down the
events that got us here explain how the
fed's past decisions and some outside
factors led to its current struggle and
detail what the fed is doing now that it
acknowledges being behind on inflation
let's get into it
to really understand how the fed fell so
far behind on inflation you've got to
understand the u.s central bank's
history the federal reserve was created
in 1913 to control price stability
meaning keep inflation in check but in
1978 congress gave the fed a dual
mandate not only did they need to hold
down inflation they were also mandated
to keep unemployment low fast forward to
2009 to combat the global financial
crisis not only did the fed lower u.s
interest rates to zero they begin a new
strategy of pumping trillions of dollars
into the economy by buying government
bonds when this idea was first proposed
many economists worried it would create
massive inflation but that didn't really
happen well except for asset prices
housing prices stock prices and bond
prices rose exponentially but not many
people complained about that in 2017
with rates still near zero president
donald trump signed a massive tax cut
and stimulus bill that pushed even more
money into the economy and drove the
unemployment rate to new historic lows
and even that didn't raise inflation in
fact economists at the fed started to
worry that inflation was too low in 2020
chairman jerome powell decided to try
something new he called it average
inflation targeting or ait ait just
meant the fed would keep interest rates
low until inflation rose above its 2
target and held above it for some time
since it had been below the 2 target for
some time
but ait turned out to be pretty bad
timing ait was introduced right before
the kovid 19 pandemic caused a wave of
business shutdowns the pandemic led to
the fed pushing trillions more dollars
into the economy to prop up businesses
along with trillions of dollars in
stimulus from the federal government
through tax cuts and direct payments to
americans still the fed insisted it
would stick with inflation targeting so
as inflation readings came in above the
fed's two percent target the fed not
only kept rates near zero it continued
pumping money into the economy chair
powell and the fed said the rising
prices would be transitory and that they
would fade away as supply chains
returned to normal and consumers
returned their pre-pandemic buying
patterns prices continued to rise and
the fed continued to say that they would
stop rising on their own but they didn't
and late last year the fed decided to
retire the word transitory even after
doing so the fed continued to hold rates
near zero and pump 120 billion dollars a
month into the economy they didn't stop
increasing the money supply until march
of this year when the consumer price
index had reached the highest in 40
years
while the fed and the government were
pumping money into the economy
increasing demand the world experienced
multiple shocks that reduced supply a
new coveted outbreak sprang up in china
shutting down major parts of the world
supply chain the u.s china trade war
continued to add tariffs to u.s imports
and upended long-standing business
arrangements and russia invaded ukraine
further disrupting the distribution of
food and oil higher demand plus lower
supply usually leads to higher prices
all of those things got us here and now
the fed is trying to make up for lost
time with many of its members even
saying that they are behind the curve
they started by raising interest rates
the normal pace in march then raised by
double the usual rate in may and in june
they raised rates at three times the
normal rate markets are expecting an
increase of that size in july but
interest rates are still more than seven
percentage points below the rate of
inflation and it's not clear how high
interest rates will have to go before
inflation gets back down to the fed's
target two percent some have argued the
fed is making a big mistake by raising
rates this fast
only time will tell
griselda's benny the butcher reminded us
recently that where you are isn't where
you have to be he said remember waking
up being broke i hated that feeling my
sacrifice and dedication
just made a few million
that's all for now see you next time
[Music]